- You know,  I'm a seven-footer
that plays with a lot of anger
and, you know, people don't have that
vision of me crying.
- Do the aliens know
that we exist?
- Do you think my best friend's an alien?
If you just wanna believe the easy answer
to make you feel better,
like most people do,
then fine.
- More travel.
We're in the airport because I'm heading to Utah
for my first-ever time in the state.
But I'm not going to be skiing. I'm going
to interview big man Rudy Gobert.
He was wildly made fun of
on social media
when he shed some tears after
not making the All-Star Game,
but then he ended the season breaking
the all-time single-season dunk record.
So now we're off to Swat Lake City
to learn more about him.
You coordinated very well
for this shoot.
So on Instagram, you commented
on a photo,
or a video,
of Joel Embiid saying that he was the
best defensive player in the league
and the most unstoppable
player in the league.
You put laughing emojis.
Why was that funny?
- Because of his accent.
- That's why it was funny.
- Yeah.
- Had nothing to do with
what he said?
- Um...yeah, what he said.
I mean, it's almost like every interview,
he tries to say that he's
the best defensive player in the league.
You don't need to say it
every interview, you know.
People are gonna look at the stats and
look at the numbers and judge for themselves.
- Are you the best defensive player
in the league?
- For you, how do you judge?
Is it the guy that makes his team better?
Or the impact?
I mean, I think it's a mix of both.
- It is. I would say it's the impact,
the impact that you have defensively.
- Yeah.
So yeah, I think I am.
- So every show I have a segment
where I have a guest take me to
that moment, that time,
that person, whatever the case may be.
All righty?
- OK.
- Take me to how you picked
your jersey number 27.
- I got drafted 27th. I was a little frustrated,
to be drafted so low,
so I thought it was a great reminder, to myself,
and to everyone that kinda didn't draft me.
- Do you know everyone that was drafted
before you?
- All of them?
That's 26 guys.
- Anthony Bennett. Victor Oladipo. Otto Porter.
Cody Zeller. Ben McLemore.
Steven Adams.
[List of names speeding up]
- I might forget a
few ones.
- Take me to a walk through the
mountains around your home.
- Yeah, when I moved here, you know,
I really–
the mountains were a big part of,
a big reason why I chose this home.
You know, it was very private.
I really like the views,
you know and I like to
go hiking.
- So when you said you got drafted to Utah
and you're like 'What is Utah?'–
did you envision this being Utah?
- I never really been around
mountains like that, so no.
- Have you gone skiing?
- I never skied in my life.
- Maybe snowboard.
- Snowball?
- Snowboard.
- Snowball fighting?
- I did snowballs before, yes,
but snowboard.
- Snowball fighting?
- Is my English that bad?
- No, I just didn't hear what you said.
- Snowboard.
- Snowboard! Snowboard, snowboard. I'm sorry.
- That's what I just said.
That's exactly what I just said.
- You needed to do, like, "snowboard"
and the motion.
- [Announcer]:
As Gobert denies Brown.
- Where did NBA defense go?
- You know, it's like a lot of animals that
are going extinct. It's kinda the same.
You know, I just think people are more focusing
on individual performance
more than winning.
- You're a defensive minded guy, and
so I think that you always kinda lean towards
players that play good defense.
Who should be the MVP?
- I'm a defensive minded guy., but I'm a
winning-minded guy.
You know, I like the guys that do all of the little
things that helps your team win.
We focus too much on the points and,
you know,
not necessarily on the guy that
created the action or the guy that set the screen.
- So who should win MVP?
- Who should win MVP?
If I had to vote,
I would pick Giannis, just because
he plays a little more defense
and the impact that he has.
- Do you talk a lot of trash on the court?
- A little bit.
- Did you talk to Giannis?
- I tried to learn some
bad words in Greek.
- What words did you learn?
- Malaka.
- Which is?
- I don't wanna say.
- You just said it in Greek!
- And then there's a way to say, like,
"You off" or, like, "You're gonna miss."
I think it's "exo."
So every free throw, I was like,
"Exo, exo."
- Did he look at you like, "How are you
speaking Greek?"
- The first time he gave me a little look.
Didn't work. No.
- So how often do you think about,
this past All-Star?
- I don't really—
I wouldn't say that I think about it.
- But you feel as though you
should have been an All-Star?
And I mean, I understand you were not thinking
about it every day, but that was a moment for you.
Like, a very frustrating moment for you.
- You know, it's human nature, you know
to be disappointed or be frustrated.
But it's always, you know, how you
bounce back, and how you react to that.
- Were you surprised at the reactions to that?
- Not really surprised. Sometimes you cry,
you don't even know why.
And just because of the perception
people have of me–you know,
I'm a seven-footer,
that plays with a lot of anger and,
you know, people don't have that
vision of me crying.
- Rudy, we love you!
Love you.
- Oh my goodness.
This is why you should get a dog.
- I'd get a dog.
- What up number 270?
- What's up?
- Yeah?
- 275.
- Nice.
- Thank you.
- It's really cool, like, everyone we passed
knows that you just broke the dunk record.
Like, I don't know if it's like that in every city that–
he knew the exact number.
- No, it's great. We really have some
great fans, and they really embrace who we are.
- So I'm curious, because you are somebody who,
in a lot of ways, embodies different identities, right?
Like, you're French. You're black.
- I'm kind of a mix of everything, so,
you know–
- Yeah.
How, I mean, how do you identify?
- As a human being, you know as
a citizen of Earth, I would say.
You know, I'm proud. My dad's black.
My mom is white.
And I'm very proud of my black side.
I'm very proud of my white side.
I'm proud of who I am.
- You had a tweet where you were defending
the places that were called "shithole countries."
Do you remember this tweet?
- Yeah, I do.
- OK.
So you said, "Do you know what
it means to have dreams?
To actually have to
work for something?
Does the fact that I left France to come
chase my dream here make France a shithole?
Or does that just apply to
African countries?"
- Like, us, you know, the big countries, like,
the top-of-the-world countries,
we actually, you know, take
a lot of resources from them.
We don't allow them to develop, so then
we call them shithole countries.
But let them develop, let them have
their own, you know leaders,
and then I think it's a
different story.
One day I was running, I was running here,
and I saw a snake in front of me.
I just went home, went back home.
- You saw the snake and turned around?
- Yeah, I turned around right away.
I saw the snake, turned around,
went home.
- How big was the snake?
- Not too big, but it's just, like, this–
- You know what, Rudy? Like, I think you
get kinda scared easily by things.
- I'm scared of snakes.
I don't care how big it is.
- Spiders?
- I don't like them, but I'm not scared of them.
- Do you, like, let out a little scream
when you see insects?
- I jump.
- You jump?
- When I saw that snake–
- It's just funny that someone so tall
would be scared of something so small.
- Yeah, it's like the elephant
and the mouse.
- I know that one thing a lot of people
don't know about you is that
you are very big into
conspiracy theories.
- Here we go.
- I knew she was gonna
talk about it.
- When did you first get into
exploring conspiracy theories?
- I think when I was, like,
15 I started to look–
- Really?
- To really question things and, you know,
there's a lot of things that are wrong,
and there's a lot of things that are
right on the internet, but I like the
fact that you can, you know, research and kinda
make your own idea of, you know,
what you think is true and
what you think is not.
- I just think it's really interesting because
conspiracy theories are just
thoughts that are out of the norm
and something you're genuinely passionate about.
Like, you spend a lot of your time,
trying to learn things that you're unsure of.
- The thing I don't–I don't really like
the term "conspiracy theory" because it
makes it look like it's negative to actually
question things when I think it's a positive thing.
If you're about to question things, don't
believe that it's true just because one person
tells you, or because you've been
taught since you were a kid that this is true.
- What should we call them instead
of conspiracy theories?
What would you call it, just so
we can have that term?
- Questions.
- Questions. You believe in questioning.
- I believe in questioning.
- Give me your
thoughts on aliens.
- I believe there's
something else.
- I will say, this is one I can get behind.
I believe that there are aliens.
- Yeah.
- I just think statistically, numbers-wise
it's much more unlikely for
us to be the only people.
- Do you think–do you think they're
down on Earth, aliens on Earth?
- I don't think there are aliens on Earth.
Do you think there are aliens on Earth?
- I think it's possible.
We don't even know what we are, really.
I mean, what are we?
- So if these aliens are on Earth,
what do they look like?
What are they doing?
Is it, like, someone in this room
could be an alien?
- Yeah, probably. It comes down to you believe
what you wanna believe
and you ask yourself what
you wanna ask yourself.
If you just wanna believe the easy answer
to make you feel better,
like most people do,
then it's fine.
- Do the aliens know that we exist?
- Do you think my best friend's an alien?
Why do you ask me like I know?
You can do your show
with an alien next time.
- "Take It There" with an alien?
- That'd be a first.
- What would you ask an alien?
- If he likes basketball.
- [Laughing]
- If he watch
"Take It There with Taylor Rooks."
- That's the best question
of them all.
You know what I wanna do when
I get up here?
I just wanna yell.
- Go ahead.
You have the worst ideas ever.
- I'm the king of the world!
Swat Lake, let's yell it.
- Swat Lake?
- Swat Lake.
- Not "Take It There"?
- But really yell, OK?
On three.
One–don't hang me
out to dry.
Two, three.
- Swat Lake!
- Didn't that feel good?
I would come out here and
yell every day.
- I've been here six years.
I've never thought about coming and yelling.
- But wasn't it liberating?
- It was really–you're too crazy.
- Bein' extra.
I don't have long enough arms to do it.
Can you take it?
-Yep.
- Put up the camera.
- Your hair. Fix your hair.
- You're right, my hair doesn't look good.
You're right.
- There we go.
- So I had a great time,
"Take It There with Taylor Rooks."
Excited to watch it.
- And look, Bleacher Report's
in your house.